In the blink of an eye,
life can change forever.
One single moment can redefine
everything that we know and believe.
In 2012,
I would face the most devastating
moments of my life
when my son, Jordan, was shot and killed
in a hate-driven shooting.
My story, Jordan’s story,
had began as one of loss.
But I refused to let it in there.
A life of loss, a story of loss,
became one of transformation,
of finding my voice
and turning my pain into purpose.
My story would become
my most important tool
in fighting this nation's gun laws.
Our personal stories have such power
to be able to bridge the deepest divisions
and to inspire change
and to bring people together.
After losing my son, I left
my 30-year career at Delta Airlines,
and I began a new career as an activist
fighting to change our nation's gun laws.
And that trajectory led me
to winning a seat in Congress,
which was once held by Newt Gingrich.
I just have to say, though,
that everything that I have done,
there was nothing more important to me
than being a mother.
It all began with me
just wanting to simply be a mother.
As a flight attendant,
I had the ability to be able
to manipulate my schedule in such a way
that I could be home for my son
every single night.
And I have to be honest
that dealing with all those
drunk passengers on the aircraft
prepared me far better
for a career in Congress
than it ever should have.
But during the Great Recession, you know,
Jordan and I had to find
fun activities that we could do
that would not break my budget.
So we spent a lot of time
in our local skating rink
where you could get pizza
for a dollar a slice.
And as Jordan got older
and he began to recognize girls,
he would say, "Mama, go over there
and skate with the adults.
You go skate with them,
and let me skate by myself.”
So off he would go,
trying to be so cool and so suave,
and I would run up to him and I'm like,
"Oh, Jordan, my baby,
I love you, oh, my baby!"
And he would do everything that he could
to get away from his crazy mama.
You know, Jordan and I
had just such a special bond,
and it would be these intimate moments
of our former life
that would fuel
my new journey to Congress.
A decade ago.
Jordan was with his father
in Jacksonville, Florida,
for Thanksgiving.
And it was Black Friday,
the day after Thanksgiving,
and Jordan was so excited because
he was going to go shopping with his boys.
He was going to go shopping at the mall,
and they were going to buy clothes
and pick up girls
and just do all the things
that these teenagers would do
when they're finding
their newfound independence.
They stopped at a convenience store
gas station just to get some chewing gum.
And Jordan was
in the back seat of the car,
and a man pulls up next to them
on the passenger side.
He starts complaining
about their loud music.
And he starts a verbal
altercation with them,
claiming that he couldn't
hear himself thinking.
They needed to turn down
their “thug” music.
He called them “gang bangers and thugs.”
And in those three and a half minutes
that man pulled a gun out of his glove box
and he shot ten rounds
into that car.
Three of those rounds
hitting and killing my only son.
And that's when I got the phone call.
The phone call that is
the worst nightmare of every parent.
And I remember Jordan's father
telling me that Jordan had been shot
and my whole world went black.
I had ...
defined my whole life
as being Jordan’s mom.
And in that single moment,
being Jordan’s mom would take on
entirely new meaning for me.
Grief, it traps you
in the prison of your own despair.
And if we let grief take control,
we risk losing not only our present
but our future as well.
If I had succumbed to that loss,
I would be enduring
not only one tragedy, but two.
So I made a decision.
I made the decision that Jordan's legacy
would not be one of loss,
but one of hope.
I chose to channel my pain into purpose.
So I began my second career as an activist
for Moms Demand Action,
for Gun Sense in America
and Everytown for Gun Safety.
While learning the unmistakable truth
that every single one of us is at risk
to falling victim to gun violence.
We all remember.
Just a little over five months ago.
A woman was killed
and four others were injured,
just visiting the doctor's office,
only about three and a half blocks
from here in midtown Atlanta.
And a year ago,
two were killed and three were injured
just down the street.
Statistically, today,
120 Americans will be shot and killed
and 200 more will be wounded.
Per capita, the United States
has more gun violence
than any other
developed nation in the world.
And polling shows it.
Over 80 percent of Americans agree
that there needs to be some kind
of common-sense gun safety legislation,
like universal background checks
for all gun sales.
But why didn't I know about any of this
before losing my son?
Why was this country not screaming
at the top of its lungs
for gun safety legislation?
So I traveled this country
advocating for common sense laws,
such as “red flag” laws
that enable law enforcement,
along with our loved ones,
to be able to take the guns
out of hands of people
that are posing a risk
to themselves or to others.
I've advocated for universal
background checks
to keep firearms out
of the hands of convicted abusers.
But by telling my story,
I’ve been able to do something
that so many people talk about
but they’re never able
to achieve in our politics:
bridge the political divide.
I'll never forget meeting a man
by the name of Reverend Rob Schenck.
As an evangelical minister,
he was the most prolific and leading voice
in the fight against abortion rights
through the 1990s.
And as we begin building our friendship,
I spoke with him at length about my need
to save as many people's
lives as possible.
We began to challenge one another,
and slowly but surely,
at great risk,
personally and professionally.
he began to stand up.
He began to stand up
as an activist for gun safety
and, as importantly, also speaking out
on pro choice policy.
Our stories are bigger than our politics.
And then in 2018,
we all watched the horror
at a Parkland, Florida high school.
And I heard all of our elected officials
talk about, "Oh, we need to make sure
that we change our dangerous gun laws.
We need to make sure
that we prevent these mass shootings."
But they did absolutely nothing.
And so I made the decision
that if Congress was not willing
to change our gun laws,
I was going to work to change Congress.
So I ran for a seat
that nobody thought I was going to win.
One of the incumbents in that seat
voted against the Voting Rights Act.
I ran for a seat that was
once held by Newt Gingrich,
and I heard all the reasons
why I could never win.
I heard all the reasons,
such as, "Oh, it was too political,"
and that I would never win
because it was unprecedented.
And I even heard that I couldn't win
because I was a Black woman.
So I took my story directly to the voters,
and I told my story at their doorsteps,
I told my story at their mailboxes,
and I told my story by their telephones,
and I won that election
by one percent of the vote.
And in Congress I've heard all the stories
of why we can't address gun safety.
They're pretty much the same reasons
why people told me
I would never win my election.
But I did what I've done
time and time again since I lost my son.
I told my story.
But in Congress,
I told my story to my colleagues
on both sides of the aisle.
To date, I have passed legislation
such as “red flag” laws.
I've supported legislation
such as background checks
for all gun sales.
And yes, I even had a hand
in helping to encourage
this administration
to create an Office
of Gun Violence Prevention.
Telling my story has helped me
find meaning in my life again
after losing my son Jordan.
It's helped me find a way to Congress
and to pass meaningful
gun safety legislation.
The power of our stories is universal.
And it lies within
each and every one of us.
Never ever be afraid
to tell yours.